no no no no no I said nobody deserves  love like the whole point the whole  point is people think that they are  entitled to things and women think they  are entitled to love men aren't that  delusional I said you don't deserve a  man that makes six figures if you're 300  pounds guys that make six figures tend  to date thin women they tend to date the  most beautiful attractive women on the  planet I don't think I am entitled to  dating a man that makes six figures but  for some reason chicks think they are  that's like a broke bum saying I deserve  I don't even want to say a Victoria's  Secret model because they look different  nowadays but like a supermodel  I deserve Beyonce you would look at him  like he's insane